on va continuer sur la vie privée dany
boon on va vous faire une carie au
mensonge
bien sûr que je comprends pas chez vous
c'est pourquoi c'est cette envie comme
ça que vous avez absolument irait précis
de sauter sur tout ce qui bouge c'est dû
à quoi c'est dû
oui parce que j'aime bien les c'est
ouvrir tout ce qui bouge
quel que soit le même pas que des femmes
mais c'est vrai c'est depuis tout petit
comme c'est parce que j'ai vécu je t'ai
élevé avec un chien et un mâle très beau
très beau labrador de grande taille
et puis c'est une liaison très peu de
temps
quand même pas duré et depuis il me
manque c'est que les filles les filles
6e soirée n'étaient pas rassurés de
savoir que vous veniez valérie la
maquilleuse la dernière fois la wii et
voulait pas que j'ai détruit à lui
rendre j'ai dit elle supporte comme ça
que vous la trompiez tout bout de champ
elle accepte ça elle adore elle dit
vasile continue ce formidable
oui c'est là c'est un set à voix mais
elle doit en souffrir quand même non pas
du tout non non parce qu'elle fait
pareil un petit peu arrêter les boîtes
échangistes quand même non j'ai arrêté
oui et non je vais je veux boire des
verres et puis des gens me touche faut
dire dany boon que vous avez un sexe
énorme tout petit minuscule
ah ça c'est très étonnant et je m'en
suis rendu compte bêtement on l'a dit
quelqu'un regardez mon sexe dans des
genres ou qu'est-ce que tu es loin et il
m'a vu à nantes est doublé à un moment
vous avez essayé de remplacer le sexe
par la drogue oui appris beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs accroché
énormément de cocaïne et là j'ai
complètement arrêté
ouais parce que je
parce que j'avais appelé la police quand
on dit leur venaient en croyant que
c'était de l'anthrax et s'est du coup je
me suis fait rigoler mais maintenant
c'est des manques je prends de l'anthrax
maintenant faut dire qu'il faut beaucoup
d'argent à dany boon c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement dépensier si je dépense a
énormément de l'argent des autres
ouais c'est ça le problème les gens s'en
rendent compte deux mois 150 mètres
carrés rue de la pompe
trois cent cinquante mille francs par
mois par jour 800 mètres carrés rue de
la pompe deux mercedes 600 oui j'en ai
déjà mais oui plusieurs couleurs tout ça
va même jusqu'à samedi
et alors c'est ce qu'est ce que vous du
luxe comme ça vous avez deux assistants
qui vous allumez vos pétanque cette
belle journée
oui encore des assistants en toge
s'ils font comme ça avec des judith à
cette baby sitter cette baie et là on en
a près une huitième pour s'occuper des
sept aussi une par jour de la semaine
deux incroyables c'est vrai avec qui je
vais au club d'échangistes pour boire
des verres et d'un seul coup
des gens nous touche c'est quand même
quitté trois mille balles au téléthon
c'est sympa j'ai appelé j'ai fait une
promesse et j'ai rien à votre art
ouais vous êtes du côté des possédants
maintenant à saillé berisha j'adore
j'adore 1
ah oui je connais des ministres et tout
ça hein
la droite maintenant dans cette france
là même limité ils sont à droite
ouais bah oui votre aide vous l'avez
déclaré votre rêve c'est un madelin qui
serait plus à droite ou un le pen plus
moderne plus moderne et mieux coiffée
plus personne ne veut vous donner son
numéro de portable
non mais j'ai je peux par contre leur
prend leurs portables
je vais pas changer un petit peu de
latitude la non vous n'aurez pas être un
peu plus sympathique avec les gens je
t'emmerde
non je sais pas vous apprendre juge pas
la solidarité la tolérance la compassion
je pas des des valeurs un peu plus
humaniste non mais j'ai toutes ces
valeurs 100 au bac en jeu
quand je croise quelqu'un je m'arrête
maintenant
et si on vous croiser avec l'arrêt en
vous écrase les bunds messieurs